[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
salut tout le monde ce mois ci j'ai pas
envie de faire un gros test de jeux
pourris je veux dire après tout c'est le
mois de noël c'est le mois où on va se
retaper la 600e rediffusion d'astérix
chez les bretons sur m6 c'est le mois où
on va se taper tous les films avec vos
pieds golbert qui repart dans le passé
pour sauver l'esprit de noël et j'ai
envie de rentrer chez moi pour voir ça
donc mais voilà comme n'aura pas le
temps de faire un gros truc on va plutôt
joué là destin et changer de vie
blessé à qui la cca d'orient nom
d'orient c'est le fil rouge de cette
émission et il est tombé sur la case
pour devenir routier il ya deux heures
donc ça fait deux heures qui joue à
retrouver simulator ça vient d'orient
il est parti d'où de lyon et il va ou
paris
[Musique]
bon ben c'est à moi mais tu as triché
l'année passée d'une case en trop et tu
te laisses la banque et écoutez monsieur
serge qu'est ce que je devais faire
est ce que je devais faire est-ce que je
devais laisser cet agent est repris par
des jeunes qui chante du rap islamiste
est en train de me prend pour un con
mais tu as raison suite mener nos
politiques géopolitiques al simulator 2
rue leur of nations est un jeu sorti en
2010 développé par les français d'ever
team alors ce jeu et honnêtement plein
de bonnes idées mais j'irai à une
simulation géopolitique sa demande de
prendre en compte tellement de
paramètres que c'est impossible de faire
un truc parfait et c'est ce que j'aime
bien dans ce jeu c'est qu'on aboutit à
des situations qui sont absolument
fantastiques
alors maintenant avec tous les patchs
qui sont sortis le jeu est quand même un
peu plus jouable qu'avant puisque dans
ma première partie j'avais été chassé du
pouvoir par exemple parce que j'avais
augmenter l'âge de la retraite d'un an
je crois et du coup il y avait 60
millions de personnes dans les rues
60 millions et 60 millions selon la
police 1 pas selon la cgt ce qui est pas
mal non vous avouerez ça veut dire que
tout le monde était dans la rue en train
de manifester un les vieux dans le
commun les enfants dans les écoles les
bébés qui venait juste de mettre de
naître c'est tout le monde était dans la
rue en train de manifester
ce qui est bien dans ce jeu c'est que tu
peux jouer et diriger ton pays un peu
avec la politique que tu veux tu peux
faire belle comme dsk ça tu peux faire
comme bayrou will à l'écran est éteint
tu peux faire comme george w bush l'âge
est envahie l'andorre parce que j'ai
donné les preuves à l'onu que l'andorre
représenter un danger pour la sécurité
internationale
donc le jeu a été fait en 2010 c'est
pour ça qu'on commence avec un sarkozy à
50 % de popularité ce qui est déjà
quelque part en dogme soit et nous voilà
aux commandes de la france qui possède
un chômage élevé et un fort déficit et
là je sais pas si c'est un bug du jeu ou
si c'est extrêmement réaliste mais en
gros dés que je fais le moindre truc il
y à des manifs partout il ya des
voitures qui brûlent dans toutes les
villes le pays entier est en grève est
la presse entière de vomi dessus
le but de ce jeu c'est simplement de
bien gérer son pays le budget le déficit
le chômage les relations internationales
est toujours de maintenir sa cote de
popularité le plus haut possible ce qui
est quasiment impossible puisque la
moindre action entraîne des conséquences
complètement disproportionnée je veux
dire je prends une décision à deux
heures du matin à 3 heures il ya huit
cent mille personnes dans les rues
comment ils font ça
[Musique]
une autre partie importante de ce jeu
c'est de gérer son agenda de rendez vous
c'est d'ailleurs une partie amusante du
jeu puisque dans ce jeu en fait vous
pouvez rencontrer tout le monde de
responsables syndicaux les ministres les
personnalités du showbiz et c est ça
vous donne plusieurs options de dialogue
genre les féliciter d envoyer chier leur
offrir un café leur faire l'amour
sauvagement sur la table d'ailleurs le
truc marrant c'est que vous pouvez leur
proposer ça dans n'importe quel ordre
non mais franchement prendre abrutir
c'est vraiment la dernière des mers d'un
café dit que c'est faire un bon café ni
que c'est faire un bon café
enfin bref de toute façon ce jeu est
bien trop compliquée pour réussir donc
finalement devant la situation qui
s'empire je décide de changer de premier
ministre qui est devenu impopulaire et
donc je choisi de remplacer françois
fillon par le chef de la secte des
adorateurs de belzébuth
vous aurez bien sûr nous sommes
totalement en phase c'est bien connu
[ __ ] que je suis en phase avec
belzébuth quoi je dois vraiment joué
comme une merde
la phrase est dans une phase difficile
mais grâce à l'aide de sa tante pour
franchir cette étape
au passage bay tant que j'y suis
j'essaye aussi de nommer aux affaires
étrangères le chef de la secte
extraterrestres des enfants astro de
vénus mais ça marche pas c'est dommage
parce que moi franchement je suis sûr
que ça aurait eu la classe dans lé dinh
avec obama bonjour je vous présente mon
premier ministre
et mon ministre des affaires étrangères
bon de toute façon je suis déjà à 0%
popularité alors bon l'europe viennent
de m'exclure de la zone euro je vois pas
pourquoi tu as j'ai quand même le droit
d'avoir belzébuth en premier ministre si
je veux quoi merde ça va donc bien
représailles je décide d'envahir la
belgique est là et j'ai eu jean françois
copé qui vient me demander si tout va
bien ça va vous la famille les enfants
les buts ça va tout va bien bref je suis
destitué et ma partie fut dit comme ça
cela dit au moins ça al'avantage d'être
une fin assez logique
six mois il m'est arrivé quand même dans
plusieurs parties que ça finisse
subitement sur un truc à la con genre tu
fais ta vie tout va bien tu veut
négocier un contrat en suisse tranquille
puis après tu vas au salon de
l'agriculture pour visiter tranquille tu
parle aux gens tranquille tu te sens pas
les par un taureau tranquille droite
nicolas attend nicolas sarkozy au salon
de l'agriculture de poitiers astronautes
qui crient mort aux vaches et je meurs
encorné par un taureau quoi enfin moral
et basta de toute façon dites vous bien
que dans ce jeu le seul moyen de ne pas
perdre c'est encore de ne pas toucher
aux claviers
bon ça qui de jouer à turin
graphique
16h45 encore une légère difficulté sur
l'a8 en direction de nice sur le secteur
de courrières 17 km après la bifurcation
vers aubagne léger ralentissement sur
800 m dans les alpes maritimes sur l'a8
en direction est très fort je suis du
côté de montbrison là ça roule bien
j'en ai quand même pour chelsea un
choeur d'hommes donc je risque de mort
était prendre un café sur une heure
millions d'euros l'ancien m
bon c'est un mois la joue et un destin
je suis koala amis du bon goût de la
poésie au revoir toilettes tycoon la
sortie en 2006 où un simulateur de
lempicka voulait servir d'écran titre la
grande classe
et quand tu sélectionnes un menu ça fait
prout c'est drôle non
ça vient de faire protéger ma vie donc
en gros vous prenez le contrôle d'un wc
publics que vous achetez pour quelque
chose comme 470 millions euros ça fait
quand même beaucoup d'argent et vous
devrez les améliorer pour gérer votre
entreprise et même faire des recherches
pour améliorer vos toilettes jusqu'à
devenir le roi du caca mais attention
parce que les recherches c'est pas donné
à tout le monde par exemple si vous
voulez améliorer le confort de vos
sièges ou la qualité de votre chasse
d'eau vous pouvez investir jusqu'à 20000
euros
si ça marche bien mais c'est tant mieux
mais sinon chute
y'a pas à dire on est pays de la poésie
donc sur l'écran de vos toilettes vous
devez d'abord acheter les différentes
composantes de vos toilettes à la chasse
d'eau le 3 le siège et le papier cul
sachant que j'essaie de poser que le
siège pour voir si les gens les faire
caca porter mais baissa pas marché
chaque composant de vos toilettes
peuvent être et doivent être améliorés
avec les sous que vous gagnez c'est
butin au début quand on commence on n'a
que des toilettes en céramique c'est les
toilettes de pauvres c'est des toilettes
où tu payes 1 euro pour couler un bronze
mais ces deux nuls et pauvres alors on
savait y en pour faire venir des riches
et pour ça on achète par exemple des
chiottes en or ou encore mieux déchaumé
mode parce que les riches ils n'aiment
pas la céramique rue ils veulent des
moules et leur cake dans des clubs du
monde
enfin bref et et est riche et aussi
quand vous vous torcher le cul avec de
la soie ou avec ça j'ai regardé la
traduction ça veut dire du vison les
visons c'est de la fourrure d'un animal
qui ressemble à une loutre sérieusement
ils ont des goûts bizarres ces riches
je peux te couper son déchirement des
mandats il a plus de quoi si on n'a pas
pu le connaître
vous pouvez aussi attaqué directement
vos concurrents en les espionnant ou en
envoyant des vandales pour casser leur
chiottes ou payer un mec pour aller
vomir dans leurs toilettes en fin de
bouche de leurs tuyaux
[Musique]
voilà mais je suis sûr que ça aurait pu
marcher si ç'avait été une mannequin
russe de 17 ans bon qu'il a fait bon ok
ça sera pas ni fera la blague ultra
prévisible
bon didon ton jeu sur les toilettes il
put up la mer quand même non merci
si en fait il en est vous le filon je
veux c'est aujourd'hui aux plus jeunes
ou chopinot fabien tour et un destin
chang'e ii
un simulator
[Musique]
quoi tu tues ferrer bah non je suis
mullings cheminots sont en grève
[Musique]
ça reste par l'épisode n'est pas fils du
ciel car ambulance simulator un jeu qui
fait partie de la merveilleuse gamme des
jeux de simulateurs allemand où tu joues
à travailler la logique du truc
m'échappe pas toujours je pense ce qui
est chiant
dans ces simulateurs c'est que si vous
avez joué gta vous ne pouvez pas jouer à
ces jeux je dire dès que je vois un mec
marcher sur le trottoir je me sens
obligé de rentrer dedans
bon ok sauf que là ça marche pas puisque
vote de la ville est remplie de
terminator regardons ça [ __ ] et aux
connards je suis une ambulance les
maquettes tranquille
en plus ce jeu me pète mes fantasmes de
l'ambulancier qui roulent à toute
vitesse dans les rues en criant tous les
feux rouges pour sauver des gens je veux
dire ici t'as pas le droit d'aller vite
maintenant ça si tu connu une voiture tu
perds des points si tu utilises tu étais
loupiotes et que c'est pas autorisé tu
perds des points si tu grille un feu
rouge tu perds des points si tu vas à 52
à l'heure alors que c'est limité à 50 tu
perds des points
[ __ ] c'est une ambulance où c'est la
voiture de derrick là honnêtement et
franchement j'ai pas vu une conduite
aussi molle depuis la traction autopia à
disneyland mais a laissé vers [ __ ]
avancé merde
oh là là mais je te jure quoi allez papy
ampute en plus il ya des feux rouges
partout dans cette idée regardez ça je
peux pas faire dix mètres sans fard en
fourrure évidemment je peux pas les
griller sinon je perds des points ça
fait échouer la mission allait passer au
vert [ __ ] c'est n'importe quoi on
regarde je heurte un poteau à deux
kilomètres heure je prends moins de 100
et là je fais un [ __ ] de tonneaux et
j'ai rien mes conneries de jeu et
connerré de feu rouge à la con économie
de bio qui conduisent
heureusement sur certaines missions
quand même que le droit d'activer la
sirène et cette sirène et les
fantastiques
parce que dès que tu l'activent les gens
deviennent fous autour de toi regardez
ça ait osé me dire que ce jeu a pas été
codé avec le cul franchement et a même
pas besoin d'être à côté regardez là je
suis sur le parking tranquille et je
m'amuse à rendre les gens fous sur la
route ça vous laissera passer un certain
vécu pression et à la poutre amour pour
sa lourd car j'ai cru que j'entends et
l'ambulance mais en fait c'était ça
pousse à vous attendez-vous non annoncé
jacques j'hallucine quoi j'ai cru que
j'entends d'une ambulance et à la
violence
il faut dire que c'est marrant quand
même de jouer comme un connard pensez
vous
poussez-vous plus je suis une ambulance
respectez pas d'autorité vous savez
c'est qui c'était fou c'est que dans
tous ces simulateurs allemand le que ce
soit et l'ambulance le camion benne des
laveuses de rulhe le centre du truc
c'est toujours la conduit puisqu'on est
toujours en véhicule alors pourquoi
est-ce que c'est toujours le point le
plus mal fait du jeu voilà pourquoi je
m'envole c'est pas comme si je les
rechercher cbl j'ai juste joué 3 minutes
pour en arriver là
qu'est ce que c'est que cette bagnole
qui volent à part ça le but du jeu c'est
toujours d'aller chercher un patient que
ce soit chez lui ou à l'endroit où il a
eu un accident et de le ramener à
l'hôpital et c'est dommage que la
conduite n'influe pas sur l'état de
santé du patient à l'arrière parce que
ça aurait été le seul endroit du jeu où
tu savoures était logique parce que hbo
excuse moi mais quand je conduis comme
ça
je vous remets le patient multiples
fractures hémorragie cérébrale
voilà mais il avait appellé pour une
appendicite à la base joyal et cela dit
je dois quand même reconnaître que les
mecs qui gère bien du trailer quand même
pour ces simulateurs je vous montrais le
trailer de bus en câbles cas c'est le
trailer officiel
les mecs qui ont fait ce trailer c'est
juste des génies pour moi parce qu'ils
arrivent à te donner l'envié d'acheter
un truc jeu qui est complètement chien
vers le monteur il a fait un super bon
boulot pour réussir à rendre ce
intéressant je mettrai le levier en
dessous de la description verra vers la
chaîne obtient la couleur trailer font
comme ça en fait bus entre cable cars
simulator dans un monde où loeb et sa
machine ne font plus qu'un dans un monde
avec des trams vienne homme qui m'a
changé le destin de tout un peuple est
cet homme
c'est vous en 2012
aastra gonds et tm ec studios présentent
le début d'une incroyable épopée qui va
changer la face de l'humanité commencé
l'aventuré extraordinaire d'un homme qui
dégivre sa vitre et qui marchent dans la
rue dans le monde de hugues marché dans
les rues ce talk et des jeunes femmes
parler à des gens viennent et trouver
des trésors secrets dans des caves avoir
donné même si ça n'a donc un [ __ ] de
rapports avec votre boulot
utilisez des laveuses de voitures des
magasins le pub et du café mettez des
lunettes de soleil
tu as vu tout ce qu'on peut faire ou h
c'est pas un jeu un peu cool quand même
je bénisse les musiques de 26 heures
la seule personne qui peut rendre des
parties de rabbi aussi épique le combat
des anciens vainqueurs
oh
[Musique]
tu as mais j'ai trop envie d'y jouer du
coup maintenant c'est les la shoah de la
musique quand même tu fais n'importe
quoi de chiant tu mets une bonne musique
dessus ça te motive trop bon ça quitte
jouer maintenant jouer au teaser bonjour
s 3 juillet destin lui sourit celui de
chauffeurs qui roulent toute la nuit
celui de politiques qui se tapent
martine aubry d'une dame pipi qui
nettoie du vomi celui d'une ambulance
qui n'a jamais conduit jouer un destin
pour changer de vie
[Musique]
bon